50 Shades of Gray one of again one of
the biggest movies why'd you turn that
down I know the author of the book or
something wanted you they wanted you I
mean it was never really like a turned
down thing like I never really got to
the point where I was properly but you
were offered it well not really I mean I
know I know the writer of the book that
before any of that happened I have met
her in um in chapter Mamon and uh and I
was talking to her and she's just like
she's just like some she's a lady from
England and I've got some wild fantasies
before the movie happened I found out
that one her friend told me like oh
that's El James that's right 50 Shades
of Gray maybe you didn't want that movie
because you thought what the hell I mean
how am I supposed to play some guys like
you know into s m or maybe I mean I
could I mean maybe you just didn't like
it you just need to work out too much is
that what it was yeah you gotta be too
good looking it's gonna be exhausting
you never go to the gym and like work on
your physique because I mean look let's
face it you're leading man you're a good
looking dude you get jacked up a bit man
we're talking you know I mean these
chicks will even go more wild I mean
I've tried I've tried I tried it it just
doesn't oh really you don't get any
muscle or tone I mean literally I just
can't I I don't understand how people do
it
foreign